today on the matt walsh show a father's
twitter thread about his quote trans
daughter
accidentally reveals the awful truth
about the trans phenomenon among
children also five headlines including
major revelations in the derek chauvin
trial has reasonable doubt already been
established
and a video that proves that our
dystopian future is
up upon us as we speak plus an easter
themed cancellation and much more today
on the matt walsh show
a few days ago i hope you celebrated
because our country celebrated a trans
day of visibility is what it's called
the trans day of visibility this was
supposed to be a time to focus on trans
people celebrate trans people
talk about the bravery and beauty of
trans people in other words it was a day
just like
every other day our experience with the
trans day of visibility
is like bill murray's experience with
groundhog's day it repeats forever
nothing changes it never ends indeed
there's there's never
been a group as fractionally tiny as the
trans population and yet so visible
there there's never been a community so
small and yet so accommodated
by society for the sake of trans people
we've
changed the english language thrown out
the rules of grammar
passed laws effectively abolished
women's sports tossed biological science
into the wood chipper come to think of
it
there has never been a population of any
size majority or minority
that's been given those sorts of
considerations most of all
we've never seen such a concerted and
effective effort
to purposefully increase the size of a
particular population
there are 10 times as many
trans-identifying people in generation z
as there are in older generations and
that figure is no accident
it's also not the organic result of
people simply feeling more
free to live in their authentic
identities live their truths
now that society is allegedly more open
and tolerant than it was in the past
no this is rather the result of
programming
children are initiated into the left's
gender theory religion
and one twitter thread meant to
commemorate our trans
day of visibility perfectly demonstrates
how this works
so it's worth looking at the thread from
a podcaster named jesse thorne
has been liked and retweeted thousands
of times by leftists who insist that
it's heartfelt
beautiful of course stunning
in it jesse explains how he and his wife
who hosts her own podcast by the way
appropriately titled one bad mother
those are her words that's her podcast
title not mine
but he explains how they first
discovered that their son was a girl
uh the left tells us that this is a
perfect explanation
of the trans phenomenon among kids and i
completely agree
actually so here's the story as he tells
it
okay he says quote i'm the parent of a
trans kid
i want to clarify what that means as
best i can because a lot of folks don't
know
or make incorrect presumptions happy
hashtag trans day of visibility
my daughter is nine when she was born we
assumed she was a boy
gave her a boy name called her he we
gave her all kinds of toys she generally
preferred the ones our culture
associates with boys
like building toys trucks and robots she
hated getting haircuts
and always wanted her hair long like my
wife's but we just figured kids hate
haircuts
she loved the jungle book especially the
part where baloo the bear dresses up in
a hula skirt
but what kid doesn't love that when she
started kindergarten my wife was bathing
her
hopefully it's not the first time the
child was bathed but uh we'll we'll get
past that
an adult friend of ours had just come
out as trans and my wife mentioned
that not all girls have vaginas and not
all boys have penises
our daughter asked some girls have
penises my wife said yes
whether you're a boy or girl wasn't
about your private parts
i'm a girl with a penis my daughter said
all of a sudden
all these things that had confused us
about her when she was younger made
sense
we went to learn about gender and kids i
mean i'm from san francisco grew up with
a trans neighbor
my wife went to sarah lawrence we were
open but pretty ignorant
well on that last point i must agree
as for the rest uh i i still am not
ready to accept
that so many people can read all of that
what i just read to you and come away
thinking
yes well clearly that child was really a
girl all along
this proves it it is possible that half
of the country has
literally gone insane but i think it's
more likely that lots of people pretend
for political and social reasons to
accept and agree with what they know
is irrational and indefensible that's
one of the things that makes this
subject so frustrating
is that when you're arguing with people
it's a very good chance that the person
you're arguing with
knows that you're right but won't admit
it
let's review the process by which jesse
and his wife teresa came to the
conclusion
that their little boy had a little girl
trapped inside him
he said this this is this is the story
that he tells it's not
me being reductive or anything like that
this is his story
he says that his son enjoyed playing
with trucks and robots
so far so normal he also hated getting
his hair cut
in my experience with my two sons this
is also quite normal
i've never known a young boy who likes
getting his hair i didn't like getting
haircut when i was a young boy
i don't think any boys like getting
their haircuts
uh the boy enjoyed the film the jungle
book again my own sons can relate i like
the jungle book too when i was a kid
but he was especially fascinated with
the scene where blue the bear wears a
hula skirt and dances around well
what child isn't fascinated with a
dancing bear and a hula skirt
now even if it were possible for a male
child to in some sense be a girl which
it's not
how could any of this be sufficient
evidence to support that conclusion
this doesn't pass the smell test even if
we accept
the fantastically delusional premise
that boys can theoretically be girls and
vice versa
in no universe this universe or the
fantasy land that the left pretends we
inhabit is this boy's behavior
indicative of anything other than
a normal boy who has normal boy-like
interests
yes the boy said that he's a girl with a
penis
but he only said that after his mother
told him
that some girls have penises if you tell
a five-year-old boy that some dragons
are three and a half feet tall
and look a lot like five-year-old boys
he's almost certain to inform you that
he is just such a dragon
what a coincidence kids are highly
suggestible
they have underdeveloped brains they
have an underdeveloped sense of the
world in reality
they can't distinguish between fact and
fiction a child at five
can't be meaningfully accused of telling
a lie because he doesn't fully
understand the difference between a lie
and the truth
you know recently i came into the
kitchen and i found a broken
glass on the floor um and uh
and and i asked my four-year-old who was
closest by
if he broke it and over the course of
the brief interrogation he told me that
he did break it but he didn't break it
but it was already broken that his
brother broke it and that the dog broke
it
we don't have a dog he he doesn't have
enough of a grasp on reality to deceive
me effectively because he's just a small
child
and everything that he says every claim
that he makes
should be understood in that context
jesse doesn't have a grasp on this basic
fact of child psychology or has chosen
to ignore it
now he goes on through the lengthy uh
thread to describe
uh how his son socially transitioned
quote unquote in kindergarten
now at the age of nine jesse is thinking
about what sorts of drugs he wants to
put the child on
he also goes into detail about the
herculean efforts needed to protect his
boy's
parentally imposed delusions this is
what he writes
we still had to and have to be on guard
at all times
every new every new care situation camp
sports babysitter
friends parents had to get a briefing we
had to check every room for jerks
because being misgendered or forced to
explain yourself is traumatic for a
young child
we basically had to be the professional
trainers for every set of grown-ups that
entered our kids lives
it was and remains exhausting i can only
imagine what it's like for adult trans
and gender non-conforming people
now jesse doesn't stop to consider why
an allegedly authentic identity should
require so much
work to preserve if his son is a girl
why does every adult in his vicinity
need to be prepped
on the proper ways to address him and
act around him my daughter
real daughter actual girl doesn't need
me to give a speech to every person she
comes across i don't need
to explain to anyone that she's a girl i
don't need to make any effort
at all to maintain her in her girl
identity
that's because there's a difference
between my daughter and his
the difference is that my daughter is a
daughter
the rest of the threat is a disturbing
as disturbing and diluted as what we've
already reviewed
but there was one brief moment
of clarity lucidity jessie wrote
quote anyway she told us her new name
grace actually she initially said greece
but we figured out what she meant not
the clearest enunciator back then
ah yes you figured out what quote
she meant that is indeed the job of a
child of a parent i should say
children say many things and often don't
know what the words that they're using
actually mean they make claims that
aren't true and that they don't know
aren't you they express desires that are
not really their desires
they say things all the time that begin
with i want and a parent has to say
no you don't really want that you think
you do but you don't
it's your job as a parent to use your
maturity and wisdom
to guide your child lead them not be led
by them
jesse heard his quote daughter say that
quote she
wanted to be called greece well jesse
knew that greece is a ridiculous name
surely
he can't actually want that name and
even if he does it's for his own good
that you guide him to a different name
because he doesn't understand the
significance of a name you can't you
can't look ahead into the future
and consider what it would be like to
actually live with that name
that's why we give our kids their name
and even parents who let their children
choose their names still don't really
let them choose them
i mean you'll notice that you very
rarely
hear uh about a trans child who chooses
their own name
and is now referred to as dragon ninja
or giant pirate or something like that
it's odd isn't it all these all these uh
all these young kids who choose their
own names quote unquote they always
end up with trendy sounding names
they never end up with the kind of name
that you would expect a five-year-old to
choose
well that's because even the parents who
let
kids choose their own name won't really
let their children choose
any name they want because
we can't let them do that because what
because because they don't understand
what it means to have a name
but if you won't let the child choose
any name they want
why would you let your children choose
whatever gender they want
why don't they as jesse said try to
figure out
what a boy really means when he says
he's a girl with a penis
why don't these parents apply their
superior wisdom and maturity
to that situation and offer their
children some much needed guidance
well because they see their children as
political statements and fashion
accessories
that's the truth they don't see their
kids as kids they don't see their kids
as human beings
jesse was quite excited to talk about
his trans daughter on his podcast
but he can't very well brag about a kid
named greece
no he needs his son to be a girl named
grace
that's much more palatable to him
jesse that is more useful to him
and this is all really about him isn't
it
now let's get to our five headlines
speaking of twitter threads i was just
reading this other thread that people
were talking about
all the uh you know the changes they
have made during the the pandemic over
the past year
uh all the things that they've done to
try to get through it and everything
and i i always read things like this
people talking about
how different life has been and and you
know for me i i say well
i really haven't changed anything at all
i've i have gone about
my normal life pretty much from day one
i mean i've made only the changes that
i've absolutely been forced to make
um but other than that i've just lived
my normal life this entire time
i've done almost all the same stuff
during the pandemic that i did before it
so this is this is an experience that i
just i just can't quite relate to
you know and that's and this was it was
it was if if you changed everything
about your life for the past year
some of that not some of it out of your
control it also depends on where you
live
but a lot of it was was probably
voluntary and unnecessary
that's the reality okay number one uh
derek chauvin
derek shove and trial george floyd's
girlfriend took the stand
yesterday and testified had some some
interesting things to reveal
among them she testified that floyd had
been rushed to the hospital
for an overdose not long before his
death a couple months before
uh here she is talking about that we
went to the hospital a couple times in
march
okay he was hospitalized and for a more
extended period of time in march right
yes that's the incident i'm talking
about okay
i went to go pick floyd up from his
house
that night i thought i was taking him to
work
he wasn't feeling good his stomach
really hurt he was doubled over in pain
just wasn't feeling well and he said he
had to go to the hospital so
i took him straight to the hospital
we went to the er and
they were checking him out in the er
and it was getting late
and i had to get home to my son so i
left that friday night
you later learned that that was uh due
to
an overdose yes
[Music]
okay so he had an overdose couple months
before and we know that he died with
fatal levels
of fentanyl in his system so
you know i'm no lawyer admittedly but
i am familiar with the phrase reasonable
doubt and uh i do know that
a a guilt has to be established beyond
reasonable doubt
one of the basic facts of our legal
system
uh it really depends on that you know
that has to be the standard everything
falls apart everything collapses
if that's not the standard
so we just have to ask ourselves um
based on on that but but on the facts
that we already knew even before that
like the fact that george floyd died
with fatal levels of fentanyl in the
system
and um and we know that from the medical
examiner we've known that for some time
so
is there is there a reasonable doubt do
we know
this this is all we have that's the only
question we should really have to ask
do we know beyond any reasonable doubt
that george floyd died because he was
choked to death
by the officer and not because he
overdosed
do we know that beyond a reasonable
doubt
i i honestly i don't see how anyone
could could say that we do
i don't see how anyone whether in that
courtroom or out in the peanut gallery
could sit there and say oh yeah we know
for sure without any doubt
that although he died with fatal levels
of fentanyl in his system and although
he had a history of overdosing
this was not an overdose death we know
that for sure without any doubt
really how do you know that see the only
thing you ever hear is well we saw the
video
yeah yes we saw the video yeah what we
didn't see was what was going on inside
his body
he went into cardiac arrest we didn't
see what caused that
that's where you have to turn to the
medical examiner autopsy you gotta look
at
what substances were in his system
it's no matter how you you could think
that derek chovin is a scumbag is the
worst guy in the world but you could
think any of that
but the justice system our court system
it's supposed to come down to however
you feel about
the the accused has his guilt been
established beyond
any reasonable doubt whatsoever and here
i would say
no no
all right number two from the daily wire
on tuesday nights
two young toddlers were dropped over a
14-foot tall barrier into the united
states at the new mexico border before
being rescued according to the
officials on wednesday u.s customs and
border protection released a statement
regarding the incident
stating that it was a life-threatening
situation involved two female tender age
toddlers mistreated and abandoned by
human
smugglers jess west of uh mount christo
ray
using filming technology as a santa
teresa
agent reportedly saw a smuggler dropping
two young children from the top of the
approach approximately 14-foot high
border barrier on tuesday night
the two smugglers quickly left the
region after discarding the girls on the
northern side of the border
and there's video of this uh it's
horrible video but you can see them
dragging these
two little girls up the uh up the fence
and dropping them
lowering them down they probably fell i
don't know i wasn't 43 they probably
fell 10 feet or something
still could have could have could have
killed them and then they're just left
on the other side of the fence
in the desert while the smugglers run
away
this is so if you're if you're very
compassionate
about illegal immigration and you want
to
invite anyone to come you don't want to
protect our
border you don't want to discourage
illegal immigration by deporting people
with your with your great compassion
this is what your compassion gets
it gets this it gets uh little girls
thrown over 14 high fences
you know if they're not sexually abused
on the way by these human smugglers
which happens all the time
extremely common that's what art that's
what your compassion gets us
now jen saki was pressed on this
particular issue this incident
and uh she kind of tried to dodge around
it get around it
here's how that went on immigration has
the white house
considered beefing up border security
now that there is video of a
three-year-old
and a five-year-old being thrown over
the
wall in new mexico beefing up border
security
well there are there's video now of a
three-year-old
i've seen the video and i think any of
us who saw the video um
were incredibly alarmed by uh the steps
of smugglers
ones that we have been quite familiar
with that we've spoken out about our
concerns
about as secretary mayorka said the
inhumane way smugglers abuse children
while profiting off parents desperation
is criminal
and morally reprehensible president
certainly agrees with that
and these kids i believe were rescued
from by uh by um individuals who are
working at the border
yes but they still got close enough
as you guys are talking about addressing
root causes in the region for a smuggler
to throw them
over a wall into the desert and i'm just
curious what
the white house is doing to stop that
from happening and are you concerned
more about the kids safety or are you
concerned about kids getting in
or tell me more about your concern here
kid safety is
as you've just mentioned the main
concern well of course it is which is
why i'm
often surprised by some of the line of
questioning in here but
i will say that our concern and our
focus
is on sending a clear message to
smuggler to
the region that uh this is not the time
to come
oh the message is it's not well yeah you
got a funny way of sending that message
the only way to send that message is
is to enforce the border force our laws
deport people when they come here
um that's the only way to send them
there's no other way to do it
you make it clear that trying to sneak
across the border is not going to work
out well for you it's not going to work
out well for your kids
it's a wasted effort you might die along
the way or get injured or
or raped along the way and um
and and all for for nothing
like that has to be the message for the
good of the people who are making this
attempt
and i've always said when it comes to
illegal immigration
you know i i don't have anything
personally against
people who try to sneak across the
border i get it if i lived in mexico
um i would try to come here too
and if it seemed like the easiest and
quickest way was to just if if i thought
that i could sneak across and like or i
could
i could see across with my kids and find
a better life
out of mexico if i thought i could do it
especially because there's a democrat in
office
then yeah i'd do it i mean
what do what do i care i'm not gonna i
gotta
unless you force me to i'm not gonna
respect the laws of this
country that i'm not even a part of yet
and even if i do respect those laws i'm
probably going to put my kids
and my family's well-being above the law
so i understand why people do it so for
me it's nothing personal
you still have to enforce the border
force the law and deport people when
they come here nothing personal
but we need to have a border to have a
country we need to have laws to have a
country
and also for the sake of the people
themselves
who get themselves killed injured um
trying to sneak over here
it's uh it's that is the most
compassionate most humane
i like that word better for this it's
that's the most humane way to handle
that is to is to enforce a law
uh number three representative park
cannon in georgia was
arrested during the signing of the voter
id law down in georgia
because she was um she was she was
banging on the governor's door
trying to interfere with the signing of
the bill and
even if you're a lawmaker you still
can't do that in fact she really she was
committing an insurrection
according to the new rules this is a
dangerous insurrectionist trying to
interfere with the democratic process
trying to stop
a law from being passed trying to stop
the democratic process from happening
she was warned that she had to stop and
go away and she didn't she was told if
you don't stop you're going to be
arrested she kept going so they arrested
her
and of course this now makes her a
martyr for the cause of racial justice
and here she is on msnbc with joy reid
talking about her newfound martyrdom are
you surprised
i guess is my question that the state
would pursue a prosecution of a black
woman
that police would arrest and detain a
black woman
given that that's the optic now that a
black woman is being punished for trying
to witness the signing of a law that
restricts black voters
i am not at all surprised that this is
what is happening
in 2021 in america
this is america and we have to remain
steadfast
in protecting the right to vote that's
why when
the late congressman john lewis took my
hand marched with me to the fulton
county government center
and voted with me in 2016 and
helped me understand why that was so
important
i'll never forget it but unfortunately
today
the only thing etched in my mind are two
things
why were they arresting me why
were they doing that and the photo
of six all white
men under a photo of a plantation
taking away black and brown
voters rights as well as all voters
rights
this is america and we have to keep on
knocking
such nonsense there's such a blatant
fraud they're not she's not even trying
not even trying to come across as
remotely authentic first of all you
could tell she rehearsed everything she
just said it was like she sounded like
she was giving a speech like she was
reading off of cue cards which maybe she
was
they signed a law taking away the rights
of black and brown americans to vote
what no they didn't
that's not what happened nothing you
just heard there
is at all true there was not one moment
not one glimmer of truth and what you
just heard there totally false
and that's not gonna be msnbc airs it of
course
you think um you think
facebook or twitter is going to take
down that video
for misinformation about voting what you
heard there is a conspiracy theory
far more delusional and on its face
dishonest
than anything you heard from even you
know this this is like
sydney powell level but worse really
it's a law taking away the the rights of
black so that's what they did they
they passed a law saying black people
can't vote well okay show me the
language if you could show me that
language and that bill i will be
right along with you um in
in in protesting it but it's not in
there
there is nothing in there that says
black people can't vote there's nothing
in there that would stop black people
from voting
nothing at all
there's nothing in there that would
affect black people more than would
affect white people
you could still vote in georgia if
you're legally eligible
which all that means is you're you're
the right age
so if you're the right age or over uh
you can vote in georgia
and you're not you're not gonna have any
trouble doing it it's gonna be perfectly
fine
if you really wanna do it'll be no
problem at all
if you need to make any preparations to
vote well you got two years until the
midterms you have
you got three four years until the
presidential you got a lot of time you
need to hire some babysitters or
whatever take you
you got a lot of time to plan for it
you'll be perfectly fine
but i love the question from joy reid
she says are you surprised
that they would arrest a black woman
that they would arrest a black woman in
this environment i thought black women
were above the law
she really thinks that she's shocked you
mean to tell me they're still arresting
black women
well yeah if you're breaking the law yes
trying to interfere with the signing of
the bill you were told to leave you're
trespassing
you're breaking the law i can't believe
that they would arrest me
why did they arrest me why um
well because you're breaking the law
you're trespassing and they told you to
stop and you didn't so that's why they
arrested you
you entitled spoiled ridiculous lying
brat
my god not even trying not even
trying to be credible or to seem
credible
all right number four i don't know if
you're ready to see this
this is straight out of uh your
dystopian nightmares but i gotta play it
for you
uh pretty terrifying it really is creepy
but no more intro needed here it is
if you want to get back to your favorite
places and feel confident they have put
your health and safety first
look for the well health safety seal
look for the well health safety seal
look for the well health safety seal i'm
dr richard carmona
the 17th surgeon general of the united
states of america
this is the well-held safety seal from
the international well-building
institute
the global authority on healthy
buildings the well house safety rating
was informed by years of research
and input from hundreds of leading
virologists public health experts
epidemiologists and building
professionals around the world
you'll see it at schools offices banks
child care centers all the places we go
the well health safety seal means that
we'll feel better
going into restaurants theaters stores
hotels
stadiums and all the places that we love
everything may look the same but the
well health safety seal means
that your health and safety are top of
mind when it comes to
cleaning and sanitizing procedures air
and water quality management emergency
preparedness programs
and health services so look for the well
health safety seal outside
and feel more confident going inside
learn more
about the well health safety rating at
wellhealthsafety.com
yeah i said that that's something that
was like a dystopian
something out of a dystopian film it's
it's also actually it reminds me more
of something out of a martin scorsese
movie it's it's this is like mob
this is something that the mafia would
do
you know you you because this is all a
racket now
right obviously the the the potential
for extortion here of of
of companies uh is very clear
now it's that we don't know based on
that like what does a company
or business have to do to get the well
health safety seal
but we can we can bet one thing is going
to cost some money
there's going to be fees there's going
to be all kinds of red tape
all kind there's going to be a whole
bureaucracy in place
to make sure that you can get that
well-held safety seal
now we sure we we sure hate it if uh
if people stop coming to your business
because it doesn't have the safety seal
we sure would hate we sure would hate it
if you're if your business if you if it
is
isn't safe because you don't have that
safety seal
we we want to protect you and make sure
that your business has the safety seal
all you got to do is pay you know ten
thousand dollars in fees and do this and
that and uh and
and and we'll make sure that you have it
i mean we know obviously that's where
this goes
especially because when they explain
what the safety seal actually means it's
okay so it means that they that they
that they clean the place
okay we already have
the health department we already we
already have laws and policies for that
and by the way if you walk into a place
and
it's not very clean it's pretty obvious
as soon as you walk in
you can tell we've all been in
restaurants and buildings you know that
are not particularly clean
we've all been in you know highway rest
stops and so on
but that's that's what this is of course
about it's about it's about creating a
whole new bureaucracy
uh to extort businesses so that they can
get the well health safety seal
which isn't going to mean that they're
any safer than any other building it's
just going to mean that they jumped
through the hoops and
paid the fees and everything else all
right um okay i wanted to play this
representative marjorie taylor green
posted her workout routine on twitter
now um
a couple things i'll say here first of
all uh
i don't have any issue with mtg
personally
and also i think there's no doubt that
she is in better shape
than probably almost everyone else in
congress the men included
however you know let's play the video
here
i just had this to me now i know this is
a crossfit thing
what she's doing right here really bad
for the knees
i mean you're asking to blow your knees
out and you're back but here watch this
what kind of pull-ups are those
it's like a fish flopping around
like a fish that falls off the hook
flopping around on the on the deck of
the boat
that is not how you do a pull-up now
this became a conversation yesterday
on social media and all the crossfit
people were coming out and saying
no that's that's that's those are real
pull-ups that's how we do that's called
kipping that's a real no that's not a
real pull-up
a real correct form on a pull-up is
you're
the only thing that should really be
moving on you are your arms
you're going up and down you bring the
chin above the bar
you come back down you want your rest
the rest of your body to be as still as
possible
because it's all supposed to be in your
upper body that's what you're working
out
when you're flopping around like that
you're not there's there's not as much
resistance because you're
it's all based on momentum now and
you're not getting the upper arm workout
that you're supposed to be getting
that offends me few things offend me
more than than poor
form at the gym if you're almost with
any workout with any with any um
resistance-based workout if you're if
you're swinging your whole body around
and doing all that
uh then you're not getting the word i
see guys like this doing dumbbell curls
you know over by the dumbbell station
and they're just swinging their whole
they're like back and forth bringing the
thing up
no keep the body still
still as i said i i there may be
like two or three people in congress men
and women who can do even one pull-up
so it's she's better off than them but
that's not that's not correct for
all right we're gonna move on to reading
the youtube comments
uh this is from toby says hey matt it
was funny watching you talk about white
boy summer asking what is it
it's actually a reference derived from
the term hot girl summer
where women hype themselves up to have a
wild fun summer
also hot dad summer is a great idea
however any dad caught wearing skinny
jeans should be cancelling the spot
no it's not hot dad summer um it's white
dad summer it's this is not about
there's we're not we're not putting
pressure okay that's it's like the
opposite of that really
because you're you're a dad that's the
point you don't have to worry about what
you look like
you've given up on that that's why
you're in the cargo shorts cargo shorts
it's not it's not for
it's it's not about style it's not about
what you look like it's all about
utility
um dj says
walsh you finally got a wikipedia page i
just checked
april fools he he
but you know you're getting banned from
the show for that one because i i really
did fall for that and i was
actually excited that i finally got the
wikipedia page that i
am entitled to and deserve
you bastard um april says being a
massage therapist myself i would find
that very
i would find that very suspicious also
that speaking of desean watson
um has been accused by like 20 massage
therapists of committing sexual assault
just being a massage therapist myself i
would find that very suspicious also
that he needed 40 massage therapists i
would understand a handful but any more
than that
and he's not seeing them because of the
massage
it's something else yeah you know it's
it's also a little bit hard for me to
judge because i have to and
i say this is no offense to you
whatsoever but um
the whole going to someone to get a
massage to me
seems weird already like i don't want
there is no circumstance where i would
ever
want to lay down and have some stranger
come
and massage me that sounds like a
nightmare as someone who
values my personal space that is a
nightmare i do not understand
how people do this as a leisurely
activity
i'm excited i get to go have a massage
today that is that's my hell
to have my personal space invaded that
way by a stranger
so to me even having one massage
therapist is a little weird
that's where i'm coming from um but yes
they have 40 different ones as
design watson apparently did yeah that
tells you something's off
carl says i have an all-access
membership but still watch the show on
youtube
comment and like it to feed the
algorithm well thank you again for your
service
you are performing a great service not
just for the show but for all mankind i
would say
device says i love how matt is not a
batologist
that moment of silence after he makes a
point just drives the truth even further
his deadpans stare and tone is
infinitely hilarious and effective
you can't come here dropping words like
a batologist
b-a-t-t-o-l-o
you can't drop a word like that in
conversation without explaining what it
means
what is that someone who studies bats i
looked it up and apparently a batologist
is someone who speaks idly
one who needlessly repeats the same
thing and speaking of writing
so i'm not that you're saying well thank
you but you're banned from the show for
using the word patologist rather than
just saying what you meant to begin with
finally i remember when my uh the
different comment i remember when my
oldest son was starting to catch on to
the tooth fairy lie
i dressed up as the tooth fairy wings
and tiara
took me quite a while to get all dolled
up i squeezed into my
to one of my old prom dresses and went
all out the next day my son told me that
he did indeed see the tooth fairy and
quote she's really pretty
made me feel awesome and the person who
left this comment is named bill
that's a little weird actually that was
trisha well trisha you you
you went to greater lengths to deceive
your child than even my wife did on this
point and i guess
well done i don't know you know as
conservatives i think one thing we all
pretend to agree
agree on anyway is that we all love the
constitution but
but have we actually taken the time to
study it and do we stand ready to defend
it that's the question we have to ask
ourselves well my friends over at
constitutioncoach.com
they have many great programs for
equipping citizens to defend liberty by
studying and living out the constitution
i have as i've been telling you about
for the last couple of weeks i've
experienced the constitutional defense
course myself
uh i'm very glad that i did so that i
can so that i could really mean it and
when i tell you that you should do this
yourself i don't regret doing it one bit
could be happier that i went through the
experience you will also feel the same
way you can get an amazing combination
of intellectual ammunition and live
classes
with rick green america's constitution
coach you also get the physical training
at the premier firearms training
facility in the nation
and you got to see this place by the way
very impressive you get it all in the
same course
you get to join hundreds of other
patriots from across the nation for a
time of learning training and fellowship
with like-minded people whether you've
shot guns your whole life or if you're
just a beginner you're somewhere in
between whatever it is i'm telling you
these people took me to a new level
a new skill level that uh i didn't think
was possible in such a short amount of
time they could do the same for you
don't just get a gun learn how to carry
with confidence and get the training you
need to defend your family go to
constitutioncoach.com rick and the
constitution coach team
have another class on april 25th but
it's going to fill up fast so
visit constitutioncoach.com today and
watch my video there to find out more
about how you can be a part of this
one-of-a-kind training
constitutioncoach.com as you
have no doubt heard candice joined the
daily wire a few weeks ago
with the premiere of her new talk show
candace the show streams on
dailywire.com
fridays at 9 00 pm eastern 8 pm central
but you'd also get the audio podcast
canvas on apple
spotify or wherever you listen to your
podcast candace hosts a series of guests
on the show each week
making for lively panel discussions and
insightful interviews
um and featured on the show this week
this friday if you listen will be none
other than
um your favorite daily wire host which
would which would be me of course
i'm on the show um and uh it's it's a
great show in general
if you can't attend the show in person
you can still tweet your questions to
the candace show for a chance to have
candace answer your question at the end
of the show
so if you need some candace owens in
your podcast feed look no further head
over to
apple podcast or spotify and subscribe
today be sure to leave a five star
review
if you like what you hear and uh make
sure of course to subscribe as well with
code candace now let's get to our daily
cancellation
we talked a little this week about we
just talked again in the comments about
the various
mythical creatures who visit our homes
or so we claim uh and i've told you
about my daughter's attempts to disprove
the fairy the fairy the tooth fairy
attempts that while quite brilliant have
been subverted by the increasingly
desperate efforts to keep the deception
going
why must we keep the deception going i
don't know ask my wife
but i thought since we're on the subject
and easter is nearly upon us
now is a good time as good a time as any
to talk about the easter bunny
and of course to cancel him as far as i
can tell
the easter bunny serves only one real
function
he is a sort of early iq test for your
child
if your child by first grade is not
asking skeptical questions about this
giant mutant bunny that allegedly sneaks
into his home and hides candy
then he's probably on the slower side no
offense now the same doesn't really
apply to santa from a child's
perspective santa is plausible
he has a backstory we know his origin we
know where he lives
we know how he gets around his method of
transportation is a bit unorthodox
admittedly but at least we know what it
is
also you see santa out in public all the
time at the mall on tv
maybe you see a fat bearded guy on a
park bench in the summer and assume that
santa is on vacation
there are songs about santa he's
ubiquitous
and a child looks at all that and thinks
to himself well surely
this can't all be one big lie well
that's a conversation for another time
the easter bunny is a different deal
he is rather shall we say half-assed he
is a half-assed fable
we've never come to any agreement as a
society about what he is
exactly where he comes from what he's
doing
how he gets around every kid is told a
different thing
i had a friend when i was little who
thought and was told
that the easter bunny was a magical man
in a bunny suit
who came in through the window at night
to hide toys that is the stuff of
nightmares
though the idea of an actual six foot
tall rabbit isn't much more comforting
my four-year-old was uh was recently
interrogating me on
this very subject now the kid thinks
that
you know when he sees me on tv i am
literally inside the physical tv
and yet even he at his age is already
raising his eyebrows a little bit over
this easter bunny thing
so he came to me and he said he said
daddy uh can the easter bunny talk
uh yes
where does he live um i guess
underground so he lives in a cave
yes the easter bunny is a giant hairy
bucktooth mammalian monster
who crawls out of his out of a cave and
breaks into our house
okay i'll go to sleep night night sleep
well
now there are some real stalker vibes to
santa also we can't deny that but
the easter bunny is terrifying on an
entirely different level
the mystery and ambiguity surrounding
him and the way that
adults are so reluctant to discuss him
the fact that we don't sing songs about
him
all of this seems to lead to the
conclusion either that the easter bunny
is an evil spirit that rose from the
shadow land because somebody like
built a parking lot over top of an
indian barrel ground or something
or that the easter bunny isn't real and
that was my own thought process when i
was when i was young
which is why even as a slow child myself
who grew into a slow adult
i still had the bunny figured out before
my parents broke the news officially
and this made it easier for my dad when
the time came for the talk it also gave
him the chance to
easily kill two holiday birds with one
stone and the conversation went like
this this i remember it vividly verbatim
it went like this
my dad said uh matt i have to talk to
you uh tell you something about the
easter bunny
now i said oh he isn't real right
yes that's what i was going to tell you
so
santa yeah same not real
okay that's verbatim how it went
that's how i learned the whole truth of
everything now as you can tell i have
been an emotionalist psychopath from a
young age but in any case the point is
the easter bunny is a bridge too far and
to top it all off
along with being creepy and bizarre the
dude is a cheapskate
santa comes with bags of present the
easter bunny gives you like
a marshmallow and a matchbox car
granted santa has the benefit of slave
labor to make all of his toys but that's
no excuse for the easter bunny
i mean you're telling me you can't
enslave a bunch of like magical
chipmunks or something to help him out
i don't know he's lazy is the problem
and horrifying
and useless he drags down the whole
squad of holiday-themed fictional
characters
he's the weak link in the chain he
doesn't deserve to shine santa's boots
let alone stand on his level
and that is why the easter bunny is
once and for all canceled just in time
for easter
i'm glad that we could have this very
important crucial conversation
as we head into the easter holiday which
i hope you enjoy and have a happy easter
and a blessed easter
and i will talk to you next week have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin